le développement du tourisme en baie de
saint brieuc passe par la réhabilitation
de l'ancien chemin de fer un projet le
remettre au goût du jour un projet
ambitieux sans dot m séduisant il y
croit dur comme fer c'est passionnés du
rail la commune de langue se donne deux
ans pour que le projet voit le jour
remettre sur rails de ce patrimoine
délaissé depuis 1958 tout cela pour le
plaisir des touristes et des gens du
coin à l'époque les gens le trouvent
élan bruyant c'était le petit train le
tortillard maintenant avec le temps il
regrette un petit peu qu'elle soit
disparu mais c'est évident la nostalgie
mais nous ne pouvons le réhabiliter que
tout la forme de sa préservation dans le
cadre de l'animation touristique
l'idée de départ c'est de préserver ces
machines dont les côtes du nord sont si
riches à langueux le petit rab allonger
la baie de saint brieuc
en fait il va circuler sur le parcours
qui existait déjà mais qui était devenu
un sentier pédestre langue saute sur
l'occasion pour développer une autre
forme de tourisme
il s'agit d'éviter les grosses
concentrations du type parts des loisirs
mais par contre d'utiliser nos nos
richesses faunistiques et floristiques
les oiseaux pour permettre à les
touristes s'y promener en toute
tranquillité sans dégrader
l'environnement
les deux partenaires comptent sur les
subventions et le mécénat pour
réhabiliter les viaducs et les voies
désaffectées
ce petit train touristique serait le
premier en bretagne alors qu'il en
existe déjà une cinquantaine en france